what up guys matt here from code tekken
tutorials just wanted to do a quick
video today basically uh going over some
coding memes because every once in a
while
we just got to have a fun video where
hopefully we can laugh a little bit
so i'll do some announcements at the end
now these are just memes that i've kind
of saved over the last month or so
that i enjoyed the most uh basically so
full disclosure i've seen all these
before but i'm gonna somewhat react like
i never have when you accidentally copy
pasta ac plus plus function from stack
overflow into your python code
yeah that's right c plus plus
is
basically a spartan
and python is the military walking in
mud you know honestly i don't get this
it's just funny and
in its context i don't know why c plus
plus would be the spartan
and uh the military guys would be python
because uh let's let's critically
analyze this in a way that almost makes
sense but probably still doesn't
c plus plus is the stronger language
clearly
however python's
easier
but you know in modern times what's
gonna win here in this picture the
military guys or the old spartan
well the military guys would just pull
out a gun and it's over
so uh yeah i think they're gonna win
but in reality uh
yeah i don't know there's probably no
sense in overanalyzing it but that's my
takeaway from this one why you should
date a programmer who understands memory
management it's the only way to fit two
pizzas in there
because one would just sit in the center
nice
yeah with this kind of management
you can get two pizzas in there however
it doesn't not
it doesn't cook as well does it if
they're not in the center i don't know
i'm not i'm not a cook but
i feel like the pizza is supposed to be
right in the center
and these are like way off to the side
so the sides might cook differently i
don't know maybe it'll be fine
you you guys tell me
also you could just put another rack in
there and just put them on different
racks
so
there's that you don't want to die with
unfinished business you'll be doomed to
walk the earth as a ghost
let me be clear leave nothing unfinished
programmers
don't look at my github everything
there's
perfectly finished
i don't leave any unfinished things up
there
and same with my series on this channel
all right programmers 30 years ago i
program in c because i understand how
computers flip and work
and look at that buff doge
programmers today please i need eight
gigabytes of ram and octa core to run my
python program smoothly
eight gigs
32 gigs you need 32 gigs to do that
there's some truth to this
like clearly it's a meme but
i feel like back in the day if you were
a programmer you really had to
understand how things work you couldn't
just freely throw things around and
instantiate all kinds of stuff just
because you you needed to get it to to
work that was a sentence
but nowadays you can't back in the day
you would run out of memory so it's that
you would you would get the lecture like
hey you can't do this because this uses
a couple bytes too much
pretty interesting you know you can
always force yourself into that scenario
if you really want to learn it that
badly i don't know maybe that'd be a
good experiment
i tried
making my program on some really old
computer
video would you guys watch that joining
our programmer humor as a beginner dev
oh look at the excitement not
understanding half the jokes
that's what you guys got me for to
explain the jokes to you
getting the job
seeing the code it's kind of true
like code code isn't as pretty as you
imagined to be like you see an end
product and the end product looks nice
and it does what it's supposed to
usually and then you see the code and
you see all these comments and questions
and like should we do it this way or
should we do it this way i don't know
why this works and stuff like that and
it's like oh
wow
yeah
that's how it is don't be too surprised
that's why they hired you to fix it
hopefully okay this is this is a
motivational post this is not a
programming so sometimes i save these if
i really like these and they they uh
click with me well your competition
isn't other people your competition is
your procrastination your ego your lack
of focus the un healthy food you're
consuming
the knowledge you neglect the negative
behavior that you're nurturing
uh so true i say i related to this so
hard
like it's really easy to look at someone
else you know in your life and be like
oh they're they're doing great why am i
not doing great or something like that
but that's that's not even fair not to
yourself not to them not to anyone it's
a lot to explain and unpack i feel like
this is pretty true you basically just
need to
like understand that you feel that way
because you can't change the way
or you can't change
the feelings that came to you they've
already come to you you know they're
coming from your mind so you basically
uh as dr k would say uh
cultivate
better karma basically
so it act better do better things
look inward
ask yourself why you're having these
thoughts and that sort of thing
and uh and just try to work on things so
i've been doing that recently i've been
trying to do pretty much all these so i
started running
for the first time a long time and oh my
i was so exhausted when i started
running
anyway i don't want to
make this all about me i just i just
want to say
that uh
you know if there's anyone else out
there that's like struggling with this
sort of thing
just one little thing at a time
try and cultivate better karma don't
don't do the terrible things that you
regret later or try not to notice that
you want to do them but instead of doing
them just just notice it
and that sort of thing and i'm i'm no
psychologist or whatever but i
i listen a lot and sometimes read
finally managed to quit vim
just smash the freaking computer oh my
gosh
you know i think
there's a misconception here
them
them is like touted as
the awesome
little lightweight
text editor or whatever that runs in
your command line
and people claim to love it and that is
great but the reality is it doesn't work
very well and i've seen it time and time
again every time i try to use it it
crashes
i lose data i get frustrated and i
basically have to like quit and i regret
ever ever launching them
every time and then i go back to it
again after seeing stuff on the internet
about how much people love it it doesn't
work right i'm sorry
i wish it did too we all do
like i was watching this streamer one
day uh strager i think his name is he
teaches like coding does code advice and
stuff and he seems to know quite a bit
and uh so i just you know i tuned in for
a minute i know it's a random side story
but it's about them
i was just uh lurking i wasn't asking
anything i was just kind of checking
things out and he said he was someone
asked like why did you decide to do uh
streaming or something and teach code
and he basically said because i noticed
i was way smarter than everyone and i
was like wow that's really pretentious
but okay whatever let's let's keep
watching for a bit
and a couple minutes later he was doing
something in vam and vim crashed on him
oops
spoilers
and vim crashed on it i was just
thinking
you're still using them you're not that
smart
the four horsemen of procrastination
napping snacks social media minor chores
oh my napping snacks and social media i
feel like the only one of these that is
actually the
uh procrastination is the social media
at least to me if i'm napping i don't
feel bad because like i'm tired
you don't try to like do hard work when
you're tired you take a nap
so i don't feel bad about that one about
the snacks um i feel about snacks if
you're eating healthy snacks then i
don't really feel bad
but if i'm going and like eating a bunch
of snickers and candy bars or whatever
yeah that's pretty bad and it's
you're probably gonna mess up your
mindset i don't know i haven't done uh
deep studies on how my mind works or
whatever but
uh yeah i think snacks only if they're
they're unhealthy social media
this one's even iffy too like yeah to
some extent it's bad i feel like if
you're going to look at stuff that's
totally unrelated to what you're working
on yeah that can be bad but
at the same time there's nothing wrong
with like
keeping up with your family a little bit
and letting people know how you're doing
and things like that and like
i think social media is really touted as
something that's like evil and awful and
i think it's just a wrong perception of
it
i feel like if you feel that way then
maybe you should check your circle a
little bit because if you're being
exposed to terrible stuff uh who's
exposing you to the terrible stuff
that's that's more of the problem than
the social media itself social media is
just it's just like youtube where you're
watching here you know
it's just people posting stuff and if
you don't like it
you watch something else or something
you know so i hope that makes sense but
i feel like there's a lot of
misconceptions here and minor chores
i have a lot of minor chores that i
probably should be doing and i would
feel really great if i did them and i
would probably get more work done after
doing them because they'd be off my mind
so i don't know if this is
intended to be
a contradictory or what no usually
people say like social media snacks that
they're they seriously mean it's
procrastination but
i just i just feel like this isn't very
accurate actually when you really drill
down there's underlying things there's
underlying things that are not really
these four things
so i don't know what do you guys think
about this someone's
is even
code
if numbers
equals equals one return false
else if
one returned false else if
to return true oh my god it just
goes on and on
what this is crazy
i don't know if this is a joke or what
oh wait and he has
it index.js
his latest update is 1 million did he do
this all the way to 1 million that's
nuts if he did
totally crazy this has got to be a joke
there's 25 pull requests he has a
subscriber thing for youtube and he's
over 100k
there's no way a coder gets over 100k
still codes like this it's a joke it's
got to be a joke one minute you're
coding and vibing to a particular music
next minute you're debugging the same
music is causing
headache yeah debugging can be a bit
painful
uh speaking of i went through a lot of
debugging yesterday
online on on stream
and
i found some really nice music for like
i don't know there was a
it was like some studio ghibli playlist
and it was beautiful it was beautiful
for debugging i was just like
i was vibing to the debugging and we
fixed it
software engineers
seen by a software engineer okay i feel
like there's a misconception here too
maybe i'm just way different than people
but i do laugh at these because i think
they're funny but when i think about
them more i realize that they're not
even correct anyway like
this is a really nice area
but if you go here and like
boot up your laptop and try to work
you're going to get so much screen glare
from the sun you won't even be able to
tell what you're doing so you literally
can't work here
anyway
and then if you try to do it at night
when the sun's down you're just going to
get swarmed by mosquitoes and stuff this
is not the dream i know it looks nice
and looks like the dream but you don't
want to be on your computer in this
situation you want to be like hiking or
swimming or you know doing something so
i'm not sure why people think uh going
out in the sun and coding is a good idea
because you basically just can't see
your screen and have managed to go code
in a nice shady area and that was all
right for a little bit but then
the benches you end up sitting on are
not very comfortable so you can't sit
there long enough to actually get a
whole lot done so giant misconception or
maybe maybe they go in their cabin or
whatever and do it but that's not what
the picture shows
so i'm always confused by these because
i just think i there's no way i've tried
this i've tried to go work in these
scenarios you can't really actually do
it software engineers dream seen by the
hr manager just put them in a little
cube
uh look how good that looks so
uncomfortable
to sit on that little stool you could
probably only sit there for like 10
minutes or at least i probably could
only sit there for 10 minutes before it
got uncomfortable
so what are these cubes actually for are
they just silent cubes
i know people are like really hating on
these
and yeah i think they're not great
but
i if you have a personal phone call
where you don't want people listening in
because maybe you're talking about some
personal matters i think these are fine
you just go in there and have your
personal
call and no one can
listen all your personal stuff
well i don't think there's anything
wrong with that but
beyond that i don't i don't know
if you're going in there they're like do
anything else i can't i can't imagine
any other scenario honestly that you
would want to go in there if you really
can't stand the noise of other people
you're probably really irritable other
underlying issues
at least that's what it is in my
experience okay this is another one that
kind of hit home for me recently that
i've been
struggling with not related to code
really
just because they're in your circle
doesn't mean they're in your corner
a lot of people will just kind of jump
onto what you're
doing or into your circle
just because they i don't know
they want something basically which it
to some extent is fine like they want to
be liked
which just is fine i guess or they want
to uh
i i don't know i don't know what people
want really
they don't often say at least not to me
or if they do it's often just a demand
of something they want me to do so i'd
kind of ignore those
because uh yeah that's not how i work
doesn't mean they're in your corner yeah
see this really hit home for me because
like when i started streaming and
telling my real life friends like so few
of them actually came and supported me
that i was like oh that hurts yeah i
don't want to expand on that too much i
made a video on my personal channel
about that which is just my uh real name
maybe i'll leave a link down below i
don't know if i really want to advertise
it actually so i probably won't but i
made a video about that topic there's a
lot of people in your circle
who are very envious of you for their
own personal problems has nothing to do
with you
and it's
it's kind of awkward if you feel that
way i would encourage you to seek help
and understanding and try to overcome
that because it's a really unhealthy
way to look at things you should
definitely support people in your circle
when they're trying new things and
taking taking risks to better themselves
and stuff
it really means a lot a lot more than
you would think because i've kind of
been on this journey for a long time and
it's it really surprised me how few
people were like encouraging it all
and and
also kind of surprised me how many of
them
well yeah that's let's just move on i
think this last one yeah that's all i
got for you guys today i just wanted to
uh
have a little fun share some thoughts
and that sort of stuff so
don't forget to hit all the buttons and
the bell if you want to see the next
videos oh yeah i said i'd do some
announcements so i guess i'll do that
the uh the patrons back up and running
and we're doing uh the member shout outs
every video i know there's also the
youtube member stuff and it's kind of
confusing because they're both but i'm
going to include them both so if you
join on youtube or on patreon you're
going to get shout outs and and
production credits and all that
and
yeah there's a couple special things on
both sides so i want to do what's right
by by the people who are showing me
support because it means a lot more than
you guys probably know it means a lot to
me i'm sure there's more i know i guess
to stay tuned i guess that's the big one
really it's just that i'm paying a lot
more attention to the patreon and
posting a lot of updates and
explanations about things over there
because
i think that's the least i could do
really
and uh yeah you know when i said
last month that i was like changing some
things and shifting things around
some people left i don't think they
really understand or stood or had some
expectations that they were gonna there
was this expectation that if you joined
patron you'd be able to tell me exactly
what to do when i'd do it like i was
some kind of men less than minimum wage
slave or something and
i i decided that for my own mental
health that was not a good model to
to stick with it's not that i won't
listen i read everything i listen to
everything but i'm gonna follow what's
uh you know my own
art and drive and all that stuff
rather than other people's because
i'm me and that's what i should do hope
that makes sense uh all right we'll see
you guys the next one peace out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you